hey guys it's max max sack we have been
getting a lot of questions about what
exactly is upgradeable on the Mac Pro so
today we're not only gonna tell you
what's upgradeable we're actually going
to show you how to do it and also let
you guys know which parts are compatible
and what we would recommend just a
little bit on later in the video now we
have right over here a new graphics card
that we're going to be adding in we have
extra storage that we're gonna add in
and some accessories and tools that we
need to do it everything is also linked
down in the video description Apple made
it extremely easy to open up the Mac Pro
all you have to just make sure it is
unplugged twist the top and pull the
whole casing off and automatically
disconnects the power supply internally
to make sure everything is safe so that
is great and we're gonna start off with
probably the easiest upgrade in the
upgrade that I would recommend to almost
everybody and that is to install your
own Ram and we already made a full Ram
upgrade guide along with a lot of
recommendations for different use cases
so we'll go ahead and leave a link to
that in the video description but just
to show you guys how you press down on
this little lock and then these little
classic covers come right out in here I
have a hundred and ninety two gigabytes
of RAM that we upgraded ourselves and
this cost me just under $700 compared to
Apple which charges a three thousand
dollars for this upgrade and it is
extremely easy to do just like that you
pull it out and then as long as you have
it aligned properly just push down and
it is locked in next let's talk about
the SSDs and this is where it gets a
little bit disappointing now yes as
these can be removed it is really easy
to do so I'll show you guys exactly how
I'm gonna take off this top cover and
I'm gonna squeeze this fan port down to
unlock it you just want to be a little
bit careful and then we're gonna push on
this front cover and then at the same
time you just want to lift straight out
that way you make sure you don't break
any clips or anything like that we can
set that aside and then right here we're
gonna pull out the SSD cover and right
under the cover we see our two SSDs that
run in raid zero and you just unscrew
them and remove
now as you can see this SSD is tiny
there are other SSDs that are similar
form factor but the actual connector
here is proprietary so at least at this
time you can't go out and buy an SSD
like this now goes even further because
these SSDs are actually linked to the t2
chip inside of the system for security
purposes meaning that if somebody steals
your system they won't be able to unplug
them and plug-in them somewhere else and
take your data but the unfortunate part
is that you will not be able to upgrade
this by yourself you're gonna have to go
to an Apple store and have them upgrade
it and link it to the t2 chip but don't
worry you could still add more storage
to your Mac Pro by yourself you can save
money or even get storage that is two to
three times faster I'll explain exactly
how and also show you but first a huge
thanks to our sponsor Micro Center for
making our Mac Pro content possible
Micra Center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive variety of
electronics from gaming VR computer
parts like processors graphics and
everything else needed to build or
upgrade a PC or Mac Micra Center has
been an authorized dealer since 1980
they have a dedicated Apple Department
with highly trained Apple sales
associates
aside from iPhone Micro Center carries
the full lineup of Apple products and
they have the largest selection of
third-party parts and accessories come
into a local Micro Center today and talk
to one of their Apple experts to order
the specific Mac Pro configuration that
best suits your needs check the link in
the description to find a local Micro
Center near you or to browse their large
selection of Apple products so how do
you go about adding extra storage to
your Mac Pro well Apple does sell an MP
X module that has a huge rate system but
that is very expensive and they also
have a caddy that you can plug in right
up here that will hold two regular hard
drives but apart from that you can
actually add in your own SSDs even
ultra-fast m2 SSDs with an a PCI card
like this now the Mac Pro has a ton of
PCI slots and even with our After Burner
card and one of these huge MPX modules
we still have a lot of ports left over
and one of these cards will only need a
4x port so you can plug it in here at
the top and as you can see once we open
up the little case screws and insert
this PCI m2 adapter in turn
Mack it shows up right there on the
desktop and then we can format SSD and
use it just as extra space now this card
right here just holds a single m2 but
you can actually get them to that
support two of them and even up to four
m2 s and that can actually make use of a
full 16 X slot meaning if you put it in
the fastest lot you can get speeds of up
to 10,000 megabytes per second
now we haven't personally tested out
this card just yet but somebody did say
that they ran it under Mac OS but you
just want to make sure that whatever you
get is listed to work with Mac OS and
this one right here will link in the
video description works out of the box
without having to do any drivers now a
lot of you guys also asks us about a
host of different cards from audio cards
to a lot of different add-in components
and all of those should work just fine
as long as you need two different things
either it has to be supported with Mac
OS or you have to be able to have
drivers you can download and install to
support whatever card you're adding in
to PCI Express slots and then the other
thing you got to make sure is that you
have a way to power it now this card
right here doesn't need additional power
but there are some cards that do need it
and the Mac Pro doesn't have a regular
set of power cables coming out of the
power supply everything is going through
the motherboard so right here I have a
Belkin power supply cable kit that plugs
into the custom power supply ports and
right now it's mainly set up to support
either six or eight pin cards a lot of
which are graphics cards but I think in
the future you might have some other
cables to give us maybe molex or SATA
power now let's talk about graphics
cards in the system we have the Radeon
pro Vega 2 graphics card and that is the
first upgrade from the base 580 the
problem is this graphics card costs two
thousand four hundred dollars and that
is a whole lot of money but you can add
in graphics cards yourselves
even with this graphics card install
that takes up four slots and the
afterburner card we still have to 16x
PCI slots here so I could add in two
very powerful graphics cards in addition
to the system and still have two more
slots available for extra storage other
plugging cards stuff like that so right
now let me show you exactly how we put
this in Apple makes it extremely easy to
remove some thumb screws right over here
you can use a screwdriver if you would
like to but it's not required and then
on the left hand side you do need a
Phillips screwdriver to remove the
little cover that holds all of the
graphics cards in next we're going to go
up here to the top and we're going to
toggle the MPX module lock and now at
the bottom of your included graphics
card you press down which will reveal
this little lever and then that allows
you to pull out the whole graphics card
now just like you pulled that one out
you can insert this one into the bottom
slot make sure it aligns properly with
the PCI Express connector and then you
can push down and you can actually put
the graphics card into any of the 16x
slots or even the 8x because most
graphics cards will work just fine in
those slots I'm gonna grab two of the
six to eight pin cables from the Belkin
power cable kit and then right here next
to the graphics card we're gonna plug in
the smaller connectors into the
motherboard and then the larger
connectors into our graphics cards I'll
go ahead and leave a link in the video
description on Apple's article on the
graphics cards that are supported in
this system now let's take a look at the
CPU and yes you can upgrade your
processor yourself not only in the
future but you can actually upgrade your
processor right now and save some money
so to do so I'm going to go ahead and
remove the afterburner card just have
easier access to our CPU and right
underneath we have two screws that hold
the CPU cover then we'll pull that off
and expose the heatsink now to unscrew
the heatsink bolts we need a t15 wrench
which is slim in at least four and a
half inches long or else it won't fit
we'll go ahead and leave a link to one
in the video description you do have to
apply quite a bit of force but don't
worry as long as it's seated properly it
will work and you want to make sure you
don't unscrew the first bolt all the way
just loosen up a bit and then go back
and forth between them to evenly remove
it and to finish remove the two bolts
that are at the top holding the heatsink
to the chassis and make sure to hold the
heatsink so it doesn't just fall down
after it's unscrewed
if you're gonna be installing a new CP
you want to make sure you clean this off
with alcohol and clean off your new CPU
before applying more thermal paste now
for this part you want to be extremely
careful and it's best to lay the Mac Pro
down we're just keeping it up for video
recording purposes because you can very
easily bend a pin on the CPU so there
you have it you could see that yes the
CPU is socketed and it is upgradable now
I don't think a lot of people are going
to upgrading their CPU right off the bat
I think most people are gonna be waiting
two three four or five years down the
line and then upgrading and at that time
a cpus are gonna get much less expensive
for example right now Apple is charging
seven thousand dollars for that twenty
eight core and I think that three years
down the line you should be able to buy
one for about fifteen hundred dollars so
that has a massive savings to get extra
performance later which is a huge
benefit with the Mac Pro and if you
don't believe me the previous Mac Pro
had a twelve core processor that Apple
charged three thousand five hundred
dollars for and now you can actually buy
one for a hundred and ninety dollars
that's slightly faster than what Apple
offered and it works perfectly fine now
if you want the ultimate performance
right now there's also another twenty
eight core processors just slightly
slower it fits in the same socket and
that one actually performs better than
Apple's twenty eight core processor
because it has a faster base clock speed
now there is one caveat with that CPU
and that's that it runs in four channel
memory just like the eight core and it's
limited to 512 gigabytes of RAM but I
think that's enough for most people you
can get that processor right now for
$3,000 so that's a savings of 4,000 -
being able to resell your a core so you
can definitely get some great deals on
performance if you're willing to swap
out your processor yourself alright guys
so our Mac Pro is now upgraded we added
in a couple different things we have
extra RAM in here and one thing you may
notice that we don't have our LG 5k
display this is a 4k and that is because
we found something out if you removed
the MPX graphics card the Thunderbolt 3
ports at the top of the Mac Pro and on
the back side they no longer work to
support a 5k or a 6k XDR display that
means if you want to use a Thunderbolt 3
display you're gonna have to keep one of
those MPX graphics card modules in now
right over here we can see that we have
our
Xeon processor we installed it back in
and works perfectly fine we have 192
gigabytes of RAM right here it's running
at the full speed you guys can see the
slots and we also have our additional
storage so I added in that PCI MDOT 2
adapter with that nvme SSD and then we
also have if we go to PCI slots we're
using up the bottom slot just that 16 X
and we have our 5700 XT AMD graphics
card and we also ran the performance
tests here this is Geekbench 5's metal
score we got about 43,000 now another
thing that came up is the fact that some
of these display ports we're not working
properly or as well as they should have
they're running a 4k 30 Hertz now only
one was outputting 60 Hertz and then if
you're plugging into a port that isn't
putting out the full performance then we
actually saw about a 15 percent loss in
Geekbench
5's metal score you guys can see it
right there so I think that is a driver
issue this is the newest latest AMD
graphics card that is the release that
is supported so hopefully the drivers
get updated so all those ports work
properly now I have another little bonus
for you guys that's stuck around we just
got in two of these Radeon 770 animator
graphics cards with 16 gigs of HBM too
so let's go ahead and pop one of these
in here and see what kind of performance
we get so not only did we install one of
those Radeon sevens also put in a Vega
64 to see how they compare and here are
the results with the Radeon 7 we have
almost 46,000 metal score which is
really quite low as I was expecting it
to be much higher than that because our
Radeon Vega 2 graphics card that gets
about 86,000 that's a massive difference
in performance for the Vega 64 that
actually did quite a bit better 57,000
841 but still not as good as it should
be so that leads me to believe that the
drivers that are designed for these
graphics cards are not utilizing them to
the full potential the clock speeds and
memory clock speeds are not as high
hopefully AMD is able to release their
own Mac OS drivers that will optimize
their graphics cards if you add them in
yourself at this point Apple is in
control of all of that and it seems like
they're pushing out the full
potential to their own graphics and px
modules but these other graphics cards
are not running as fast as they could so
at this time if you want to upgrade if
you don't need more than 8 gigabytes of
video memory I would suggest a Vegas 64
because we are getting the best
performance with that and then if you do
need more than that go for the Radeon 7
you don't need that much performance if
you're doing simpler tasks that 5700 XT
is actually the latest graphics card
isn't performing almost as good as the
radio and 7 it has better encoding
options with the new encoder that's
built into there and of course it is
much less expensive keep in mind that
this is just one benchmark and we are
going to be doing a comparison between
the $2,400 upgrade option for the vega
to compare to these other graphics cards
to see how they compare in the real
world because there is a massive
difference in price between them so
there you guys have it everything that
you can upgrade on the mac pro how to do
it and our recommendations on what you
should get from Apple and what you can
do yourself with which parts are the
most worth it let us know if you have
any questions down in comment section
below and click right above to subscribe
so you guys don't miss out on other
videos and we also have links in the
video description thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]